get interacted with somebody that what
they do in their area of expertise they
do it in a such a fluid effortless way
which is in a way intimidating to you to
say I can never be like this person in
this area and it actually discourages
you from giving your best well in
reality there's nine different forms of
intelligence that you need to know about
and if you directly compete with another
person in an area that comes to them
very naturally good luck beating them
the goal is to find out which one of
these nine is yours so stick around to
the very end on top of the nine there's
one additional one that we rarely hear
people talk about but I think there's
there's something there there are people
who have that that is a form of Genius
but I'll share that with you at the end
so let's go through it so the nine
different forms of genes
foreign
number one numerical intelligence now
what are we talking about with this
these are people that numbers come
naturally to them they see everything
through the lens of a mathematician
everything is angles formulas numbers
data stats they love anything to do with
that riddles puzzles strategies let's
solve this problem let's solve that
problem to them everything the world is
a big problem that we're all trying to
solve and they think they have the right
solution for every problem next one is
musical intelligence you ever meet
people they can pick up a musical
instrument and just start learning by
themselves naturally there's people like
that out there guitar piano they hear
something they can come back 30 minutes
later and they can just do it on the
piano or they can be in the car saying
and they can come back and do it right
now you may say I can never do something
like that but there are some people that
naturally have musical intelligence it
just may not be you third type of
intelligence a spatial intelligence this
is the kind of intelligence where
somebody like me I go into a house if
it's already fully designed Arts
Furniture where the bedroom is where the
office is where the gym is where the
saunas I'll say wow this is beautiful
but ask me to do it from the beginning
to design a house with where everything
needs to be I have no desire to do it I
don't have that lens some people have
that over there you need to put a clock
over here would be a great place for us
to put this little thing here some
people have this some people don't if
that's you that is a form of
intelligence called spatial intelligence
next one is linguistic intelligence this
is people that writing abilities put an
email together incredible giving a
message delivering a speech at the right
time using the right words in a
sensitive situation they know how to do
it perfectly well okay that is one of
their strengths that is a form of an
Intelligence on how to put words
together and delivered in a beautiful
way next form of intelligence is
kinesthetic intelligence these are
people that are naturally athletes the
way they dance the way they walk the way
they perform the way they play sports
you give them a basketball boom you're
like if this is the first time you play
basketball it's my second time how did
you just do that I don't know it's kind
of easy hey here's a baseball hit it
boom just naturally they have that
athletic ability to pick things up you
ever met somebody that has zero
kinesthetic intelligence and you try to
see them dance have you ever heard
somebody or met somebody that took dance
lessons for five years and still when
you watch these people dance you're like
you know how to dance but you're still
doing it in a very mechanical way versus
somebody who naturally can pick it up
within two three months of watching
people they dance as if they've been
dancing for 10 years it's a form of
Genius it's a form of intelligence next
one is interpersonal intelligence these
are people that are very self-aware
they're sometimes labeled as loners but
they process issues very well by
themselves they have the ability to
reason they don't have to be around
people they can be by themselves and
they're fine they're enjoying their own
company this is very hard for some
people to do but for them they can be
known as critical thinkers as well as
their thinking and processing issues
this is a form of intelligence now this
next one is a complete opposite called
interpersonal intelligence these are
people that put them in a room they'll
meet someone they'll exchange cards in
formation make friends very quickly
they're able to negotiate they're able
to broker deals they're able to talk to
others and get them to collaborate and
get them to work together they're Bridge
Builders it's a very very good quality
in the world of business and that is a
form of intelligence called
interpersonal intelligence next one is
naturalistic intelligence my son my
oldest son since he was eight months old
I've gone back in this one house that we
had and I would walk him by the ball and
he would walk to the dirt crawl to the
dirt at eight nine months I'm like what
is this kid doing I would take him on
the other side to see if he wants to
play and build Lego he would go to the
dirt and he would start playing with
dirt he's a year and a half he meets a
cat he just goes up to a cat Fearless he
starts petting the cat he sees an iguana
he just walks up to them starts petting
them this kid in nature he is just a
very unique character on how he views
nature it's a beautiful thing to see
this kid we took him to Alaska and we're
walking in the mountains going up it's
as if it was his favorite trip ever he
would much rather go to Alaska to see
nature then go to Bahamas to be on the
beach he loves nature some people have
it naturally and it is a form of
intelligence next one is existential
intelligence you ever you ever had a
friend that they would ask all these
deep questions you're like Johnny what's
wrong with you tell me why we exist how
do we end up here philosopher Aristotle
said this but Plato said this but
Socrates said this but this person said
that and how about this what happens
when we die who came first very
spiritual very much about philosophy
ideas that is their form of intelligence
which it's called existential
intelligence and last but not least this
is not one of the nine but I think it's
something for us to be thinking about
because the whole concept of
photographic memory some say oh that's
not a real thing there's no such thing
as photographic memory matter of fact if
you got photographic memory what a
miserable life you have to live you ever
had a phone that had one too many
pictures videos text files what happened
to the phone it's slowed down if you do
have a photographic memory and you have
all of these things here in your brain
what a miserable life that individual
could have but there are certain people
that maybe you've met who can remember
names some remember faces some can
recite a conversation with them yet 17
years ago and you're like how the hell
do you do that some it's in formation
some it's numbers and stats that just
remember certain things some do have
that if you look at it from the
scientific standpoint a lot of people
will tell you there's no such thing as
photographic memory but that is a gift
that some people have and you know if
you do know people like that you know
exactly what I'm talking about if you
don't you're like Pat there's always
something like that exist there are some
people that have that and that helps
them as well in many different areas of
their life to me that is a form of
Genius as well so you may be asking Pat
what do you want me to do with this
information this is great I'm glad I
learned I didn't know some of this stuff
but how what do I do now about this very
simple number one the person that overly
impressed you is it got an intelligence
in a certain area that's not yours but
what is your area of intelligence and
what you need to do to increase that two
levels that maybe this person cannot
reach right my son I got two boys one of
them is intrapersonal the other one is
interpersonal one is naturalistic
intelligence the other one is very
kinesthetic linguistic both of them have
but what are you going to do you're
going to try to compete them with an
area that's natural to them against this
side it's not fair or get him to be
natural no it's saying hey this is the
area you're strong at all these other
areas let's try to improve it and learn
a little bit for the heck of it but are
we going to become a Mozart one day
probably not are you going to become the
next LeBron James or the next probably
not but let's do it anyways for the heck
of it to learn and improve so we can
have a wide range of experiences in life
so personal other people around you are
working with as well as your kids this
information was interesting to me so I
decided to share it with you now if you
enjoyed this video I got another video I
did four months ago shocking facts about
Monopoly with education right it's an
interesting phenomenon on what's going
on with colleges and universities if
you've never seen this clip before this
video before click here to watch that
video take care everybody bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]